[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans ce
journal du lundi 12 octobre voici les
titres le plateau de satory à versailles
épicentre du développement des robots
militaires le groupe nexter en livrent
actuellement une soixantaine à l'armée
de terre et des équipements du futur qui
sont également évalués sur le camp
militaire par la section technique de
l'armée de terre focus dans cette
édition sur et qualys cette association
avec le soutien du département pilote
hui chantier d'insertion dans les
yvelines
le principe accompagner des personnes
sans emploi exemple dans cette édition à
carrières sous poissy et à la verrière
et puis retour sur le 3e challenge de
l'amitié il était organisée vendredi au
golf de l'île de loisirs à saint quentin
en yvelines et dix associations dont 4
du territoire s'affrontaient sur le
green est mais avant de développer ces
titres le point sur l'épidémie de colis
de 19 dans les yvelines avec vous allez
le voir des chiffres qui sont à la
hausse le taux d'incidence c'est à dire
le nombre de tests positifs pour 100000
habitants est désormais 281 19,02 soit
une progression de 80 points une semaine
taux de positivité à 14 7%
la tension hospitalière se fait de plus
en plus ressentir en ile-de-france avec
à 41% et des lits de réanimation
désormais occupés 262 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier dans les yvelines +83
en une semaine depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 576 personnes sont
décédées dans les établissements de
santé yvelinois
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres et des
robots militaires du futur développer
sur le plateau de satory à versailles
nexter robotics livrent actuellement une
soixantaine de ces robots alarme et r&d
système télécommandé pour la
reconnaissance sur des terrains hostiles
regardait ce sujet de nicolas landry et
juste après une interview également en
tournée sur le plateau de satory à
versailles avec le service le la section
technique de l'armée de terre qui évalue
justement ces technologies regardez ils
sont 56 robots comme celui ci est
actuellement en cours de livraison dans
des régiments de l'armée de terre des
systèmes multifonctions destinés aux
activités de défense et de protection
civile
ils sont développées ici un exter
robotics à satory le but principal est
en fait d'avoir une capacité
d'observation pour l'infanterie débarqué
à également avoir donc un périmètre une
connaissance environnementale du
véhicule lors d'un débarquement mais
aussi de pouvoir donc faire des tâches
de déminage à l'origine de ce robot un
besoin du gign installé sur le plateau
de satory les recherches commencent en
2010 le système de base est aujourd'hui
équipée de quatre caméras et l'intérêt
majeur du robot en fait c'est son
adaptabilité
c'est à dire que donc d'une part on peut
changer la mobilité de ce dernier en
quelques secondes on va pouvoir y
installer toutes sortes de modules
mission que ce soit des caméras
thermiques des caméras bas niveaux de
lumière des haut parleurs des
simulateurs de son des fumigènes des
distributeurs etc
ce module avec un canon dessus en fait
est un destructeur c'est un canon à eau
qui propulse eu de l'eau en fête à très
haute pression et qui permet de
neutraliser des mines ou des idées donc
le but étant en fait d'envoyer de l'eau
à très haute pression pour pouvoir
séparer le détonateur de la charge utile
nexter robotics est l'entité spécialiste
des systèmes robotiques du groupe
industriel nexter elle est composée
d'une vingtaine de collaborateurs son
activité de recherche et développement
actuel porte sur les systèmes robotiques
plus lourd on met beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts comme je voulais 10 sur les
plus gros robots donc les machines plus
lourdes qui sont encore en devenir donc
et dont on a besoin de montrer de
prouver la robustesse et l'intérêt
opérationnel la plus-value opérationnel
il n'est pas question chez nous de faire
des systèmes entièrement autonome donc
l'homme reste le maître du jeu reste le
maître de la machine et donc nos
applications
nos efforts en fait vont sur
l'optimisation de la relation entre
l'homme et le robot de manière à ce que
le couple homme robot soit le plus
performant possible surveillance
logistique reconnaissance d'itinéraires
et combat les axes de travail pour
développer ces robots en phase de
prototypage
même si des systèmes sont déjà utilisés
comme celui ci c'est un robot en fait
qui permet de patrouiller dans la banque
de france et qui permet justement de
faire la détection d'un truand est
également don de la surveillance il ya
par exemple un trou dans la clôture ou
s'il ya des comportements suspects
aujourd'hui nexter robotics compte une
trentaine de clients dans le monde comme
les forces spéciales américaines
elle réalise 10 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et pour approfondir
ce sujet nous sommes actuellement sur le
plateau de satory à versailles avec le
la section technique de l'armée de terre
est avec nous il ya deux interlocuteurs
le colonel bruno bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes vous de l'équipe de la
direction de la stat est également le
chef de bataillon christopher bonjour
oui bonjour de l'équipe de marc de la
stat alors là stade je le rappelle c'est
la section technique de l'armée terre
concrètement colonel bruno qu'est ce que
la stat quelles sont ses missions et
bien la star a comme mission d'évaluer
d'un point de vue purement opérationnel
tous les équipements du futur de l'armée
de terre quand on dit l'armée terre
c'est au sens large ça va de
l'hélicoptère des parachutes des
véhicules blindés de l'armement de
l'informatique des moyens de
télécommunication et on le voit d'un
point de vue purement opérationnel à la
stat même si elle s'appelle technique
vous n'avez que des gens qui ont un vrai
passé militaire d'opérationnel sur les
théâtres d'opérations extérieures et
donc on est en présence ici drobo qu'on
aura peut-être l'occasion de voir à
l'image
voilà qu'avec quel type de robot
travaillez vous alors face à vous c'est
le premier standard de robotique
terrestre scorpions donc deux
composantes des robots pour l'infanterie
le petit qui se trouve ici et le moyen
qui se trouve là il y en a un troisième
qui est destiné à
aux sapeurs qui en cours de
développement donc le petit c'est un
robot qui mini robots qui fait moins de
3 kg il permet avant qu un fantassin
rentrer dans une pièce de pouvoir avoir
une vision savoir s'il ya des insurgés à
l'intérieur voir s'il ya des ouvertures
et donc il sert à faire fusible donc
nous on vérifie sur le terrain que le ce
matériel correspond bien aux besoins
militaires et le moyen c'est un mini
robots modulaire ou la halle avantage on
peut mettre davantage de kits comme vous
pouvez le voir tout à l'heure en restant
le plus pédagogique possible quels types
de justement de tests vous leur fait
subir à ces robots jusqu'à l'extrémité
de ce que les militaires ont demandé ce
qu'on nous sommes donc des sachants
d'humains du combat donc on les pousse
dans tout ce que l'on connaît du combat
en zone urbaine pour le tout petit et
pour le moyen aussi c'est à dire qu'on
les pousse dans les zones habitées dans
à l'intérieur même des caves dans les
métros et ainsi de suite
donc on les pousse à chaque fois au
maximum de ce qu'on a pu exiger d'un
point de vue opérationnel vis-à-vis de
l'industriel alors ces robots ils sont
intégrés au programme scorpion ce qu'on
le rappelle l'armée de terre a connu une
révolution technique
au travers de ce programme scorpion dans
les grands lignes ça consiste en quoi ce
programme alors le programme scorpion il
faut bien le re cadré c'est un programme
dit médian c'est à dire ce sont tous les
véhicules que l'on peut pas jeter par la
porte d'un avion donc son parachute abl
il ne flotte pas dans l'eau phoebe mais
ce ne sont pas non plus tous les
véhicules lourds du combat type le char
lourdes combat conception des véhicules
mais diantre est protégé et surtout qui
préfigure le combat dit info valorisé
avec des échanges numériques entre
chacune des plateformes le coeur de
scorpions c'est d'abord son informatique
de combat et on va peut-être se répéter
un petit peu mais comment vous intégrez
justement ces robots dans les théâtres
d'opérations alors ces robots pour le
petit le moyen sont d'autres
l'infanterie à titre exploratoire
donc en fait justement l'infanterie elle
va utiliser ces robots en zone urbaine
ou en zones ouvertes de jour de nuit à
pied ou en vie à partir de véhicules
pour justement voir comment est-ce que
elle va vouloir utiliser ces robots pour
peut-être en accueillir plus des plus
petits des plus gros donc là c'est une
dotation exploratoire en revanche pour
le robot du génie là c'est un
renouvellement d'une capacité et comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure le but
c'est d'avoir un robot qui sert à
protéger le sapeur pour éviter que quand
il ya par exemple un engin explosif
improvisé
que ce soit le sapeur qui naquit explose
sur sur cet engin donc on envoie le
robot en éclaireur pour lever le doute
donc on a parlé de ces robots une
dernière question là il s'agit de robots
on va dire de petite taille ce qui a
déplu gros robots qui sont testés ici
alors après vous avez un robot un peu
plus gros qui servira aux équipes du
génie pour tout ce qui est des minages
c'est un robot de 20 25 kg ensuite
l'armée de terre ne s'en ne s'interdit
pas de réfléchir à des robots mule c'est
à dire qu'ils sont capables de porter
des sacs à dos porter les munitions voir
porter des blessés mais l'a pour
l'instant ce n'est que du travail
de veille technologique vis-à-vis des
industriels qui sont autour de nous
merci colonel bruno et merci au chef de
bataillon christopher merci de nous
avoir accueillis ici au sein de la
section technique de l'armée tard je
vous le rappelle on est sur le plateau
de satory à versailles dans le reste de
l'actualité les antilles pma pour toutes
les femmes et les antis gp a réuni
samedi à versailles 1700 personnes selon
la police 5000 selon les organisateurs
sont venus manifester devant les locaux
de la préfecture des yvelines
une mobilisation nationale dans
plusieurs villes de france à l'appel
d'un mouvement associatif unitaire
rassemblée sous le label marchand
enfants on y retrouve la manif pour tous
allianz vita à l'afc ou encore les
veilleurs le mouvement on demande le
retrait du projet de loi bioéthique
porté par le gouvernement le sénat doit
examiner le texte en seconde lecture
d'ici le premier trimestre 2001 21
accompagner des personnes sans emploi et
rencontrant des difficultés sociales
c'est le but et le principe des
chantiers d'insertion et des initiatives
souvent soutenu par le département est
porté par une agence qui s'appelle une
associée une association pardon qui
s'appelle equality la présidente de l'
agence activity qui fait partie du
département qui est l' agence
d'insertion du département et pierre
bédier le président du département sont
venus justement visité deux de ses
chantiers d'insertion le reportage à ce
sujet de mélanie poker des masques des
coussins des sacs
cet atelier textile emploie une
vingtaine de salariés en insertion à
conflans sainte honorine
il travaille pour et qualys une
association on a des accompagnements qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à deux ans on règle
le virage sur un chantier
la règle commune à nos chantiers c'est
plutôt un an après un parcours chez nous
en moyenne c'est un an avec beaucoup
d'accompagnement vers les formations les
formations qu'on n'espère plus tôt
qualifiant pour eux et sinon c'est aussi
des emplois très diversifiée dans le
domaine de la vente du service à la
personne et qualys gère huit chantiers
d'insertion dont deux à conflans sainte
honorine les jardins de cocaïne sont
spécialisés dans le maraîchage bio une
activité accompagné par l' agence
départementale activités
il présente depuis cinq ans la capacité
pas seulement d'accompagner en
fonctionnement mais on a mis des moyens
de l'investissement pourquoi je vous dis
c'est original parce que dans
l'insertion dans l'action sociale par
nature on est souvent dans le
fonctionnement pas dans l'investissement
or ces structures lorsqu'elle se lance
sur des nouveaux défis sont des nouveaux
projets elles ont besoin d' le coup de
pouce de départ de l'investissement et
c'est se comporter honda cr on l'apporté
plusieurs années de suite et en projets
d'investissements ces cinquante mille
euros par an implanté dans les yvelines
depuis 1978 et qualys est présente dans
neuf départements franciliens dans
l'oise et le loiret elle accompagne 200
salariés en insertion et à la verrière
justement une salle du scarabée
accueille depuis le 24 septembre un
chantier d'insertion pour confectionner
des masques de protection l'objectif
c'est produire dix mille dix mille
masques de protection pour ensuite les
distribuer aux habitants de la ville
bixente n'a rien senti steban et la voix
d'eléonore sinoquet mise en place par l'
agence activity l'association et qualys
et la mairie de la verrière
une quinzaine d'employés en contrat
d'insertion confectionne des masques il
travaille répartis sur une dizaine de
machines actuellement de l'avant 16
personnes et ce qui se passe c'est
qu'ils apprennent à faire de la couture
affaires de masques et à des personnes
qui sont qualifiés et puis à d'autres
personnes qui n'ont jamais jamais
pratiqué donc ils apprennent le
maniement de la machine et à coudre la
salle khobar du scarabée a été choisie
pour héberger cette initiative pendant
les quatre mois de l'opération
c'est effectivement la ville qui met à
disposition cette salle du scarabée
il ya également la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a financé les machines
il ya des particuliers qui font des dons
de tissus
c'est 100% coton pour ceux qui veulent
faire des dons on a vraiment besoin
d'eux depuis l'instauration il y a deux
semaines le groupe a déjà fabriqué plus
de 150 masque avec une majorité de
tissus recyclés
les employés ont pour la plupart étaient
formés sur place à la couture quand même
en fait
max tous les jours canac et kuzi bien
irak et après la cousine quoi moi je
faisais pas du tout de couture avant
j'ai vraiment découvert ici
au début on touche un peu à tout pour
pour apprendre et ensuite on va plutôt
se spécialiser ses versets de les
personnes qui ont plus de mal à coudons
vont passer pour faire leur passage nous
devons découdre et comme ça après on va
avoir une production plus optimale le
chantier d'insertion se tient jusqu'en
janvier date à laquelle les dix mille
masques devraient être achevés et
distribués aux citoyens de la commune de
la verrière un nouveau directeur
académique pour le département des
yvelines luc femmes 58 ans a été pris a
été désigné a pris ses fonctions la
semaine dernière cet ancien instituteur
remplaçant
antoine destrés qui était en poste
depuis un an suite à la démission de
serge clément visé par des soupçons de
harcèlement sexuel antoine destrés été
nommé à la tête de l'académie de paris
luc femme de son côté arrive des landes
ou là et était il était également
directeur académique est les élus du
conseil communautaire de saint quentin
en yvelines se sont réunis jeudi 8
octobre pour une nouvelle séance au
programme près de 40 délibération votée
voici ce qu'il faut retenir nouveau
conseil d'agglomération en octobre et un
petit nouveau dans l'assemblée mustapha
larbaoui devient élus communautaires de
la ville de trappes c'est en
remplacement d'hotman nassr ou
démissionnaire est devenu premier
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france alors aujourd'hui je
rentre dans des enceintes ou
où il se prend des décisions importantes
voilà laquelle je suis associé
maintenant et dont c'est impressionnant
et pour le coup ça me fait très plaisir
de représenter les trappistes à la
communauté d'agglomération et de
participer aux travaux de toute l'agglo
au menu de la séance près de 40 des
libérations désignation des
représentants de l'agglomération au sein
des différents conseils d'administration
elles notamment pour la pépinière promo
paul et la mission locale ce qui est 16
les élus communautaires se sont
prononcés favorablement aussi pour un
nouveau projet concernant la ferme de
bulles loyer à magny les hameaux
soixante dix pour 3 contre création sur
place prochainement d'une ferme école
qui formera aux métiers de l'agriculture
bio et qui sera géré par l'association
graines d'avenir
c'est un projet qui a été portée par
tous la ferme de belloy y est c'est un
élément historique essentiel bertrand
guillon on parlera mieux que moi puisque
c'est sur sa commune nous avons à cet
endroit là une ferme qui je ne remonte
pas au moyen-âge mais dans l'histoire
plus récente celle de la ville nouvelle
et le lieu qui a accueilli
l'établissement public d'aménagement qui
a réalisé la l'élaboration et la
construction de la ville nouvelle donc
il fallait trouver une nouvelle
destination à ce site une ferme huit
hectares c'est compliqué on a pu trouver
un projet qui concilie social
environnement le conseil d'agglomération
a également voté pour la création d'une
piste cyclable à lille de loisirs sites
olympiques de paris 2024
saint-quentin-en-yvelines contribuera à
hauteur de 220 mille euros sur l'île de
loisirs nous n'avions pas de piste
cyclable donc évidemment pour sept
points la sportif en lien avec les jo
c'était important
mais il ya un autre point essentiel
aussi c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
grand
nombre de salariés qui arrive à la gare
de montigny saint quentin en yvelines et
qui se rendre à la clé saint-pierre et
leur permettre demain d'avoir une piste
cyclable qui leur permet de se rendre à
vélo jusqu'à leur lieu de travail et
vice versa le soir c'est une très belle
évolution que nous souhaitons au niveau
des mobilités sur saint quentin en
yvelines
parmi les autres décisions à retenir
notamment le soutien de saint quentin en
yvelines à hauteur de 105 mille euros
pour la construction de logements
sociaux aux clayes-sous-bois prochaine
séance le 19 novembre à 19h30
là le sport pour refermer ce journal et
du golfe le 3e challenge de l'amitié
était organisée vendredi au golf de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines dix associations s'affrontaient
sur le green
retour sur l'événement avec patrice
carmouze sur des images d'yves hub stand
vergès c'est sur les greens du golf de
saint quentin en yvelines qui a eu lieu
vendredi 9 octobre
la troisième édition du challenge de
l'amitié créée en 2018 ce challenge met
aux prises dix associations dont 4
représente le territoire de saint
quentin d'un sexe au golf de
montigny-le-bretonneux l'association sky
egolf 2018
l'association sportive bluegreen de
saint quentin en yvelines et le golf
club de voisins-le-bretonneux le
regroupement de ces dix associations
donne une certaine force de frappe comme
l'expliquent philippe dubreuil de
président du golf club vit sinois encore
peu à peu près de sa fait dans les 1400
golf r quand même si on a cet additionne
l'ensemble des membres de ces
associations donc ça pèse quand même
quelque chose 3 évidemment les
conditions sanitaires ont bousculé le
calendrier prévu mais après un premier
challenge qui s'est déroulée au golf de
marivaux mois de septembre dernier la
compétition 9 octobre a connu un vrai
succès comme le rappelle philippe
dubreuil
on a beaucoup de monde fectivement on
était 68 golfeurs aujourd'hui
effectivement à table je pense qu'en
fait 50 ou 60 aussi d'esprit premier
effectivement claude viollet et donc il
est bien là et ça c'est ce qui me reste
plus quà à ce jeu c'est l'association
sportive de montigny qui a remporté ce
deuxième tour devant le bouc gris de
saint quentin et sky wolf 2018
la formule est toujours identique 6
joueurs et deux remplaçants représente
chaque association et chaque équipe
d'autres comporter au moins une femme
chaque l'association donc présente une
équipe
cette équipe donc ces six titulaires
avec une dame minimum ça c'est une règle
effectivement importante
on a un double et quatre simples le
double 1 chapman et quatre simples en
qui jouent au scrabble ford plus de
remplaçants prochaine étape du challenge
de l'amitié au mois de mars au golf
national et dans un instant ne manquez
pas le 7-8 sport pour faire le tour de
l'actualité des résultats sportifs du
week-end et s'est présentée par vous
mélanie poker bonsoir commença alors
quel est le menu ce soir du 7 8 sport le
menu de ce soir on reviendra sur un
match de handball plaisir échoue à un
petit point de son adversaire le club de
houille le vésinet carrière remporte lui
son tout premier match en nationale 3 du
côté du baseball nous allons essayer de
découvrir quelle est la recette des
jeunes pousses des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux
les équipes de moins de 9 12 et 15 ans
sont imbattables
ou presque et nous découvrirons une
activité sportive plutôt méconnu le
hockey à quad subaquatique se pratique
dans près de 2500 club en france nous
sommes allés au chesnay et où se
trouvait dans un instant le cetud sport
c'est tous les lundis sur tv soit 118
18h30 rediffusion à 19 heures 30 et 23
heures voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité retour et dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]